[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
asesor científico de france 24 y médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia gracias por acompañar nuevos
doctores hoy hablaremos de los programas
de vacunación y las dos dosis que
utilizan las fórmulas que ya están
siendo administradas en diferentes
países hablemos de las diferencias entre
las dosis de las vacunas la primera en
términos de anticuerpos tiempos de
respuesta y protección de contagio con
la segunda dosis
recordemos que las vacunas tienen diseño
uno de los diseños es colocar una dosis
y un refuerzo de eso hay en este momento
la del país
la vacuna astrazéneca la vacuna moderna
requiere 22 pero de otras casas
farmacéuticas como la vacuna de jiangxi
que sólo requiere una dosis porque la
segunda dosis porque la dosis que evoca
una fuerte respuesta inmunológica en la
segunda dosis para que dure mucho más la
inmunidad
entonces la dosis de refuerzo en ese
contexto y de acuerdo al diseño de la
vacuna se necesita para mayor tiempo de
protección ante la escasez que hay de
vacunas conviene aplicar una sola dosis
al mayor número de personas
no lo que es conveniente es que la
inmunidad sea completa sean las 22
ha habido digamos que una una
deficiencia en el suministro y por eso
se han vacunado con una sola dosis
alguna parte de la población pero lo que
se requiere es vacunar con dos dosis en
algunas personas está prolongando el
tiempo para la vacunación pero no cree
que no lo vayan a recibir asegurados
en un tiempo más prolongado pero sin
duda lo que hay que hacer es la
vacunación como debe ser dos dosis y en
los periodos que se recomiendan en los
estudios técnicos israel ha inyectado la
primera dosis a cerca del 50 por ciento
de despoblación porque ha sido tan
exitosa su estrategia como ha logrado
vacunar a la mitad de sus habitantes
primero compraron las vacunas
anticipando a su población segundo
tienen un fuerte sistema de salud
pública es una alianza público-privada
la más grande que han hecho para
desarrollar esta pandemia lo tercero es
la disciplina de la población en donde
la confianza hacia la vacuna es muy
importante y tienen un sistema logístico
que ha permitido que todas las personas
accedan no solamente la primera sino ya
la segunda dosis y los resultados que
nos han mostrado en israel en la
disminución impresionante de casos
hospitalizados y ya en la segunda 2 es
una reducción en la mortalidad que pues
llama la atención aunque son estudios
iniciales pero muy importantes y que
llaman a la vacunación masiva si alguien
recibe la vacuna doctor puede quitarse
ya el tapabocas volver a la vida normal
y eso es algo muy importante nosotros
necesitamos que se va a poner la mayoría
de personas para retirar el tapabocas
porque porque hay linajes hay otros
tipos de ellos que pueden estar
circulando y pueden hacer inefectiva la
una leche que nos vacunemos no quiere
decir que no retiremos el medio en
nuestra media de bioseguridad vacunación
disminución las de la aceleración de
casos y vacunación masiva en la
estrategia para que al final del año
probablemente ya podamos retirar las
medias de seguridad pero por lo que
resta del año tenemos que continuar
igual como saber si una vacuna es
confiable el doctor
es muy importante que todas las vacunas
tienen estudios clínicos es decir son
personas que son realmente héroes que
son voluntarios que han recibido la
vacuna o no la reciben cartas en placebo
esos estudios clínicos muestran si es
eficaz si es segura cuántas dosis son y
cuánto dura la inmunidad esos factores
son los que determinan si la vacuna es
segura
por eso las entidades regulatorias de
cada país deben asegurar que el
biológico que ingresé al país se cumpla
con esos preceptos que tengan los
estudios y así la gente se puede
inmunizar
la segunda vacuna solo es de refuerzo ya
me respondió que la primera dosis es
indispensable pero cuál es entonces la
principal función de la segunda dosis
si esa segunda dosis la primera dosis
dice bueno estoy acá por favor sistema
inmunológico actúe empieza a funcionar
la segunda dosis refuerza para que todas
las células del sistema recuerden ese
antígeno y hagan y evoquen una respuesta
inmunológica sostenida y mucho más
fuerte mucho más consistente la segunda
dosis es una dosis de refuerzo permite
que el sistema inmunológico desarrolle
es esta fuerza que se necesita para
controlar el anti no es el virus en este
caso pues muchas gracias doctor carlos
eduardo pérez asesor científico de
france 24 por sus recomendaciones
también es médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia y
gracias a ustedes por su compañía siguen
france24
[Música]